[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
endlich ist sie wieder da die erdbeeren
und rhabarber zeit und ich freue mich
sehr heute geht es ein richtig cooles
rezept ich mache eine epa rabatt mit
cookie dough also das ganze dann aus
dieser text heißt super lecker und
zuallererst stelle ich jetzt mal den
mürbeteig her
ihr könnt das ganze natürlich auch mit
einem quark öl teig machen oder mit
rührteig aber in der tat form finde ich
es mit dem möbel tag schon richtig
perfekt für den mürbeteig verwende ich
300 gramm mehl 200 gramm kalte butter
100 gramm zucker eine prise salz vanille
extrakt eineiige und ich habe ich noch
backfest des schocks
das ist wenn ihr ihn kennt der 123
mücken oder hier in dem fall 3 2 1
ich nehme jetzt erstmal die kalte butter
kommt hier in die rührschüssel gemeinsam
mit dem zucker salz und wandel extrakt
und ich mache es immer mal wieder anders
als entweder in der küchenmaschine oder
einfach ohne küchengeräte mit der hand
im mixer mach ich's auch ganz gerne
einfach damit ihr willst mir beträgt
kann man echt unterschiedlich herstellen
heute mit dem knethaken
so könnt ihr nämlich schauen was euch am
besten passt
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt das geld dazu
und jetzt einfach das mehl und bei
mürbeteig mache ich es immer so ich
nehme die zutaten 123 also immer ein
teil zucker zweiteiler butter drei teile
mail
und egal welche backform größe ich nehme
ich nehme dann einfach ein eigelb dazu
das bindet den teig noch mal schön und
ich finde dadurch bekommen wir auch eine
tolle farbe und hält eben auch besser
zusammen
[Applaus]
wenn die masse dann schön krümelig ist
nehmt ihr einfach die hände
da braucht die butter einfach so ein
bisschen die hand wärme im mixer oder in
der küchenmaschine geht es natürlich
schneller aber wer keine küchengeräte
hat macht wirklich einfach so und hier
ist einfach mal wichtig dass der betrag
nicht warm wird das heißt wirklich nur
so lange kneten bis der teig schön
zusammen kommt ansonsten wird er nicht
möbel sondern hart
[Musik]
das geht ganz schnell hier kommen jetzt
noch die schoko später hier rein diese
shops
[Musik]
jetzt lege ich den mac einfach in einen
teller decken ab und stellen für eine
stunde kühl und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal dass rhabarber erdball
kompott machen ich habe den rhabarber
und da habe ich jetzt ein holsteiner
blut es gibt auch wohl steinar ege blöd
da ist das innere nämlich auch road
ziert den roten rhabarber gewählt weil
die etwas milder sind also nicht ganz so
sauer
und es gibt ja noch den grünen rabatt.de
nimmt man auch ganz gerne für kompott
aber der ist echt mega sunrise hat
einfach ganz viel oxalsäure enthalten
die oxalsäure kennt ihr auch von spinat
wenn ihr das mal gegessen habe dann also
bei mir auf den pfählen bildet sich dann
wie so ein belag so kitschig und genau
da könnte einfach mal entweder im
supermarkt oder auf dem wochenmarkt
nachfragen
ich könnte jetzt auch ganz lieb den
herrn schneider und die nasa vom globus
die nahm ich meine cousine die arbeitet
dort und haben extra nochmal für mich
nachgeschaut welche rava war das ist
nichts es hier einfach die faserigen
enden ab und ganz junger rabatt er muss
gar nicht geschält werden
ihr könnt da auch gern mal meinen
rhabarberkuchen rezept aus dem letzten
jahr ausprobieren darf ich nämlich
rubber streuselkuchen gemacht und
rhabarber limonade alles in einem lecker
kann ich den rhabarber in kleine stücke
schneiden und ich mache jetzt hier eine
relativ große menge also für den kuchen
viel zu viel aber ich werde es
rhabarberkompott einfach aufheben
und wenn ich mir schon mal die arbeit
macht dann mache ich gleich ein paar
gläschen also so können das auch
wirklich super vorbereiten und wenn ihr
die torte oder ein anderes der selber
noch mal machen möchte oder einfach das
kompott zum beispiel in joghurt ein rät
ihr habt dann echt ganz super schnell
ein dass er deswegen macht lieber auch
gleich eine große menge wir mal gespannt
ob der schneiden mal anmerken dass ich
sehr gegrüßt habe als er schneider und
malern aus dem globus wiesental
falls das nicht merken ist da was wenn
ihr beim globus diesem tag seit geht
einfach mal in die optisch
gemüseabteilung und grüßt die beiden
ganz ganz lieb von mir da freuen sich
bestimmt
so hat den rabatt gebe ich jetzt hier
einfach in einen großen topf der top
sollte auch wirklich ausreichend groß
sein damit das kompott später gut kochen
kann jetzt hier den zucker dazu
und ich nehme jetzt hier auch eigentlich
relativ wenig zucker also nicht wie bei
einer marmelade dann etwas zitronensaft
für den geschmack gebe ich noch vanille
extrakt ist so das passt nämlich super
und auch noch eine prise zimt und alles
kurz durchrühren die erdbeeren noch
nicht mit dazu geben
ich lasse es nämlich den rhabarber
erstmal abgedeckt wird eine stunde
stehen damit er einfach wasser ziehen
kann
das ist so ein schönes gemüse ist ein
bisschen komisch weil rabba wird ja oft
so süßen sachen verarbeitet und man
denkt deswegen oft im amt ist aber mainz
und gemüse die erdbeere ist - und der
kürbis war das was man eine beere so
spielt hat die natur also ist abdeckung
für eine stunde stehen lassen und dann
machen wir erstmal denke ich mit dem
gedanken
sie ist meine tat form die benutze ich
bleiben und hier habe ich jetzt den mir
beträgt das schön kalt den einmal kurz
durchkneten
jetzt ein bisschen näher auf die silikon
matte ich mache die tat jetzt 30 cm groß
ihr könnt aber auch gern kleiner machen
wenn ihr einfach auf dem blog auf die
rezepte geht dann gibt es diesen
umrechnen das geht dann ganz einfach
und jetzt einfach etwa 5 cm größe
ausrollen als die tat form damit ich
gleich einen rand hochziehen kann
guckt man eben auch manchmal wenn ich
unten kein mehl mehr hat an den rand ein
bisschen mehl und zieht das mehl mit der
palette dann unter den teig der teig
bleibt jetzt automatisch etwas dicker
durch die schokostückchen sondern auch
völlig okay so erreicht nämlich genau
perfekt für die 30 zentimeter form jetzt
auf der aus rolf starb auf rollen jetzt
etwas schwieriger durch die
schokostückchen vorsichtig reinlegen und
anpassen
sobald der teig schön gleichmäßig liegt
einfach mit der palette den brand nach
außen weg streifen
so wird der abschluss richtig schön
jetzt friere ich die tat noch mal ein so
behält sie beim backen nämlich
wunderschön ihre form
etwa eine halbe stunde ist schon reichen
und dann wird sie wieder richtig schön
kalt und dem restlichen teig den schweiß
ich nicht weg da mache ich einfach
gleich mit nikotin
die tat ist es schön gefroren und ich
gebe es jetzt so in den backofen kann
sie jetzt einmal direkt durch baken und
kann dann in der zwischenzeit schon mal
mich um das kopf weiter kümmern
[Musik]
hier sieht man jetzt ganz gut dass sich
die flüssigkeit richtig toll gesammelt
hat das wetter tolle rhabarber limonade
aber nein wir kochen sie ich gebe es
hier noch ein bisschen stärker dazu zum
binden weil ich sehr gleich ihnen die
tat gebe genau was uns relativ fest sein
kann so viel verkochte jetzt auch nicht
jetzt aufkochen lassen und dann den herd
runterstellen und etwas zehn minuten
einkochen lassen sodass der rhabarber
schön weich wird und danach gebe ich
doch erst die erdbeeren dazu erst zum
schluss damit sie eben nicht zu weich
werden lehrt werden die brauchen nicht
so lange wie der rhabarber wenn ihr
merkt dass der rhabarber nicht so viel
flüssigkeit abgegeben hat und einfach
schon relativ fest wird aber noch nicht
weit genug ist dann könnte einfach noch
mal ein halbes glas wasser zufügen und
bisschen weiter kochen lassen so wird er
auch dann wirklich schön weich
[Musik]
jetzt ist er aber weicht die erdbahn
kommen dazu und die lasse ich jetzt
einfach nur noch so ein bis zwei minuten
mit erhitzen so dass sie wirklich nicht
zerfallen und ich noch so ein bisschen
bis habt und danach fühle ich dann das
kompott um und lass es ab gehören
genauso wie die tat wie lass sie auch
abkühlen
[Musik]
so sieht die tat jetzt aus und ihr seht
auch die form ist superschön geblieben
das einzige was mir passieren kann dass
sie am rand des mit disler hochgeht dann
drückt jetzt einfach ganz leicht runter
und wenn ihr den tipp beherzigt und die
touch in ein feld vor dem backen dann
könnt ihr euch das blind backen sparen
also mit backpapier und hülsenfrüchten
ziemlich nämlich echt immer ziemlich
umständlich jetzt lasse ich die tat hier
abkühlen und da geht es später mit der
vanille creme mitarbeiter für die
vanillecreme verwende ich 400 gramm
sahne 80 gramm puderzucker ein paar
tropfen karamell aroma wandel extrakt
sommerbad und 500 gramm quark
ich nehme jetzt zuerst den quark der
kommt in die rührschüssel bis in der
vanille extrakt ein paar tropfen und
carmela roma ist kein muss aber recht
gut dann butter zucker kurz verrühren
[Musik]
die sich langsam die sahne dazu und
wetter die creme mit seiner bordstein
schlagen
jetzt die star auslösen
das vorsichtig und bei mürbeteig hätte
ich die tat nicht weil der teig schon
genug fett enthält
und jetzt unten einfach mit einer
palette den boden noch lösen
wenn ich aber zum beispiel quark öl teig
habe oder hefeteig dann fällt die tat
form einfach mit bisschen backt rems
bray so schön ein schöner kriegs da
nehme ich jetzt immer ein bisschen was
von der creme dann das kompott hat eine
richtig tolle farben
das soll ein bisschen rein und es ist
auch nicht ganz fest gehört auch so dann
einfach beim rhein streichen so ein
bisschen marmorieren jetzt immer wieder
bisschen creme ein bisschen vom kompott
rein
ich glaube ja die wird sehr gut
[Musik]
und dann habe ich ein paar erdbeeren und
legst du noch als deko obendrauf
[Musik]
sie hatte die torte jetzt noch mal für
eine stunde in den kühlschrank gestellt
jetzt ist auch das kompott ein bisschen
fester und wie es damals üblich selber
ganze zeit dürfen hier mal die männer
probieren wir frauen der welt kommen zu
kurz so knusprig der tat kann man noch
ein bisschen ziehen lassen denn dann
wird der kirchsteig auch mal ein
bisschen feiner
aber ihr wisst ich werde nicht gerne
beim filmen lassen gefilmt es war die
richtige entscheidung vorhin habe ich
noch kurz gedacht mensch ich habe mich
verschätzt ich hätte mehr creme nehmen
soll
aber jetzt finde ich sie so wunderschön
am anfang sah es so ein bisschen leer
aus mit den etwa obendrauf und vor allem
mit dem concorde richtig lecker fruchtig
und erfrischend das komplott ist nicht
so süß also wirklich damit ganz leicht
nur süß um die säure auszugleichen
und der kuchen ist und sozusagen perfekt
die schokostückchen die schmeckt man
sonst im nachgang also echt ne richtig
geniale kombination aus mit zeigt mit
schokoladenstückchen dieser leichten
quark sahne creme und diesem fruchtig
leicht sie es noch ein paar sessel
lecker solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
nachmachen
vor allem können sie die tat auch
wirklich super gut vorbereiten und am
tag vorher den boden backen ihr könnt am
gleichen tag dann einfach die sonne rein
film und dann mitnehmen oder euren
gästen zu holen oder einfach selber
verlassen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen das rezept gibt es auf cds -
blog.de mit der umrechnung tabelle könnt
ihr wie gesagt die tat vom hoch oder
runter rechnen auf eure perfekte größe
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei bis zum
nächsten mal dieses stück ist ihm sicher
[Musik]